hey guys this is the all-new Reuben
report for three episodes and I'm still
calling it all new I am still dave rubin
and we have a first timer with us Jackie
Schechter welcome to the show thank you
i guess i'm all new to write europe
you're truly all new I'm like semi new
refurbished or something and we have
somewhat old-timer the old jalopy yes
I'm I was very young looking through the
use of hair tie yeah but but i got to
know we go yeah Jim Guthrie here thanks
I'm all I'm ready to get her cuz i do a
meditation on the 405 for about 45
minutes before i get here yeah car
doesn't move you just sit there and now
i'm ready well actually the reason we
moved to riot was because I knew would
make your commute a little worse little
wars really rile you up before we talk
about politics and I thought that would
do it okay all right we got a great show
for you so here we go if you like your
terrorism in under 140 characters well
then anonymous might be coming for you
anonymous then now well-known hacker
group has released over 9000 Twitter
account names that allegedly support
Isis the group is hoping that by
publicly releasing the Twitter account
names at Twitter itself will take action
and remove the accounts in a post on
medium anonymous implores the public to
join the fight to stop Isis from
spreading his message online it reads in
part the more attention it gets more
likely it comes Twitter takes action to
remove these accounts and making a
serious impact on the ability of Isis to
spread propaganda and recruit new
members all right so you guys know I'm
an addicted Twitterer I tweet roughly
4,000 times per day I do tweet a lot
about Isis I'm not an Isis supporter in
case that in case you were wondering or
not I'm not not an Isis supporter um but
was anonymous I'm not an Isis supporter
ya know that one um but the idea that
anonymous is going after the ISIS people
on Twitter for a second I was like well
I do tweet about Isis does that mean
that they're coming after me did you
know clean did either one of you have
that fear no although I don't I tweet
more about my cat yeah anonymous is
going after people who tweet too much
about their time the cat the cat people
are worse than the is people know
they're gonna go Isis and then they're
gonna come after us yeah no I don't I
don't tweet that much about I do tweet a
lot I don't tweet a lot of
Isis yeah I think this is good this is a
good use of their skill set yeah teamed
up with a couple of other hacker groups
so this seems like a positive use of
social media yeah so we've talked a lot
about the ISIS situation before and
social media and should we be playing
these videos should we show the pictures
all that stuff I anonymous is doing
something good here right well David's I
don't think you have to worry about them
thinking you did support ice a Jew
supporting Isis probably not will be
like us wearing the cats for making pro
dog tweets yeah okay so I think you're
safe there I don't think the problem I
think anonymous should I think they're
wasting time my twitter is a big problem
and I think that's just in our world it
seems big like everyone always says well
they're helping the propaganda but you
think that's not really I would argue
though that that I know the terrorist
groups are very popular on social media
and they use websites and the web forum
decide their message very effectively so
it may not be Twitter alone but it's
certainly part of the mechanism that
they used to spread their propaganda
when when I sworn at CNN we had a
translator who worked very diligently to
help us decipher what was going on in a
lot of these chat rooms and online
forums or a lot of these messages were
being sent so it may actually be
happening right under our noses and
under 140 characters right but in in a
very effective means especially if
you're trying to recruit young people
right so maybe two things can be true at
once that it's a good recruiting tool
but on the other hand in the media world
we're over blowing the I don't so so
Twitter is now the moral police Twitter
can tell who's on what side in a war so
Isis is also Isis is all bad but the
people fighting Isis is good sometimes
if they're on our side with like a rebel
yard or sometimes it's the anti-isis pro
Saudi Arabia but anti-iran I mean we
don't know who the these people are
and I think it's ridiculous that Twitter
takes it upon themselves to decipher who
is good and who was bad in the Middle
East we don't know who's good at the
whole reason why we have Isis is because
we didn't understand the sunni-shia
connection in the first place when we
went into Iraq right and now we've
unleashed a thousand-year-old war and
that's what this is about so can can use
Twitter if you're in the
KKK can you use twitter if you're like
Alec Baldwin and you say negative things
about gay people when they put a camera
in your face I use Twitter if you're in
a neo-nazi organization can you use
twitter if you're considered by the
Southern Poverty Law Institute a racist
organization like the Focus on the
Family so who can use Twitter and who
can it's a very squiggly line of
morality right so baby Twitter should
stay the out of it and just provide
a platform of people and tweet in
144 characters right so just be clear
we're talking about to sever things here
so one is whether Twitter will allow
people to post this stuff and the other
is whether anonymous is going to go
after these accounts I'm for freedom
speech in all cases so i would say let
the accounts be there even though
they're up to no good and i would say
twitter or any of the social media sites
shouldn't be policing what people could
put out we agree we're agreeing all that
all be the descent oh yeah you want to
clean us up getting put it yeah anything
else too no I mean I just think that you
have a responsibility if you're going to
run some sort of social media site yeah
people and regulation isn't it really
impossible to police it like anonymous
is going to do whatever they're gonna do
before for Twitter to constantly be
hunting these people down is it yeah I
mean it's not going to be ideal it's not
going you're not gonna get everybody and
you're not gonna necessarily go after
everybody but I think that having a rule
in place that you can't tweet out
heading videos or that you're not using
their social media platform for bullying
right I mean I think that those are good
rules to have what do you think that the
argument that people should see these
things cuz when we've done it when we
talked about before I'm 5050 on it like
on one hand I don't want to help the
propaganda on the other hand they're
doing horrible I mean I watched the
video of the Jordanian pilot burning it
was the most awful thing I'd literally
think you are seeing in my life and I
don't know and on one hand I think
people should see it to see how horrible
it is and know what we're dealing with
and then on the other hand I don't want
to a DIN the prop again right i mean i
think you can go out and search for it
online if that's something you want to
see i know that i don't have the stomach
for it i can I can certainly hear about
it and no it's terrible and that's
enough for me to suffer me to want to
get angry and do something or to know
where I stand on a particular issue and
if the internet is open and available
and you can go look for it if you
actually need to see it yeah but I don't
know that we necessarily need to
mechanisms in place to promote it and
that seems to be what a lot of these
platforms have been for organizations
like I all right bring us home now you
knew when it said you watch those videos
yeah beheadings in the learning yeah and
but you people don't know this about you
and I might be outing you here but you
watched four seasons of according to Jim
so it's like you got a steal you've got
a ton or toughness that I don't know I'm
used to torturing myself and really from
according to Jim the only thing that
could be worse was watching a human burn
so was it curiosity yeah but you know I
just felt I just felt I should know
about it in light of everything that I
do and talk matter that I should know
but knowing it happened or or seeing the
pictures right before that wasn't enough
like you wanted I just felt like I
should see it I don't know why maybe it
was just awful morbid curiosity George a
damn video while more horrible than
according to Jim still funnier yeah all
right what do you think should anonymous
be taking down these Twitter accounts
should Twitter be taking down these
Twitter accounts let us know in the
comments right down below noted group of
crazy people good at making lists a
spokesperson for Isis claims that the
terror organization aims to blow up the
White House Big Ben and the Eiffel Tower
then conquer Paris Rome Portugal and
Spain oddly the spokesperson for Isis
noted that everyone is welcome in this
new home saying there is no difference
between an era in a non-arab nor between
black and white the spokesperson also
said here the American fraternize with
the Arab and the African with the
European and the eastern with the
Western Isis they're tweeting their
facebooking they're telling us the
that they're going to blow up this is
these are an effective group of people I
don't like them very much but like
they're good at the scare machine feel
like they wash national lampoon's
european vacation like look kids big van
parliament like you're the things are in
a while right like they have a map like
one of those eighties movies and they're
just picking things to blow up everybody
like these are just base threats right
like they just say stuff and that no I
definitely think they're gonna blow up
the White House like it's gonna happen
they've been able to achieve all their
goals so far yeah they can't hold on to
Mosul but I think they're gonna be able
to invade washington DC right think it's
gonna happen know if we know anything
about the security at the White House
the Secret Service mostly drunk and not
doing
job so there is a chance right that you
are you are correct and it all started
with that one guy who made it all the
way into the White House indoor inside
an off-duty guy and he reminded me a lot
of George Bush because just like George
Bush he also made it into the white
house without being elected and he was
drunk I think and then we had the Secret
Service guys that were drunk so there's
a lot a lot of drinking happening around
do you find any fear in this kind of
stuff we get it they're doing terrible
stuff I don't want to you know undermine
what they're doing or downplay it but
when they say this kind of stuff is this
just craziness I mean it looks like a
recruiting technique right i mean
they're going out to their supporters
and saying we're going after the big
stuff it's not creative right and we
thought get a little fancy with it right
i know i mean i'm not worried i think
that we've got those things protected
and on lockdown and i think that we are
a very reactionary society we tend to
get all crazy about stuff like blowing
up planes after we've already blown up
planes yeah so I don't know that we're
prepared for what's coming next because
I don't think we think about what's
coming next but I would imagine that
landmarks in major cities are protected
in some capacity right and isn't the
whole point of what they want to do is
they want to scare us into changing how
we behave isn't that the real threat the
chances that someone from Isis is coming
here to the head us or blow up the White
House pretty small you look at all the
terrorists exactly that what they can do
is get us to change how we behave change
how we have security in places to start
giving up our rights things like the
patriot act things like that isn't that
what's really going on I don't agree
with you Dave I don't think given up I
was just thinking I was talking about
this with a friend while I was getting a
full body x-ray from an airport worker
and I don't think we overreacted
whatsoever does it's the fact that the
think that Isis thinks they can scarce
by threatening the blow up the White
House that's like--that's thinking they
can the world trade center or the
Pentagon or something that's never gonna
happen right so I way thank you for
taking your shoes off before you did the
show we might we wanted to make sure you
were my pleasure and we I'm I'm also
facing the east yeah but um uh I mean I
you know it the only would think the
only way I would believe that they'll be
able to blow up the White House is if
there was a UH intelligence briefing
paper in time
Isis wants to blow up that white house
and that we ignore then they would blow
up the White House only if we ignored
the White House briefing paper yeah is
there anything you so you see what he's
doing there we see what you do a game
play and they ignored it no but is
there anything in the Eiffel Tower I
mean it's a landmark but yeah what is in
the Eiffel Tower just toy I think geez I
think it's filled with cheese cream
cheese yeah I mean bringing that down
doesn't seem like i'm doing a strategic
move on their part other than eiffel
tower people are not gonna be happy with
you know i mean it's not it's yeah but
you're not you're not taking out in and
it's a landmark right but you're not
getting necessarily getting people and
that how confident are you that the
government is keeping us safe haha are
you do you feel kind of like I go we
talk about this all the time i go
through NSA at the airport tsa probably
hate you I go through TSA and it's
always like wow these people like if
this seems like an SNL skit to me
basically like this doesn't seem like
the type of people that are really
trained to do anything do you guys feel
that the government is keeping us safe
no but I move from DZ to California so I
feel like the farther away i get from
that the better off I am yeah yoga and
kale will save me yeah the Secret
Service is turning into an AAA
organization I don't have much faith in
the TSA which I'm not have ever been to
an airport trying to get through TSA
yeah but there's always two lanes open
six clothes and there's literally well
like they say TSA stands for thousands
standing around and I think that's what
it is yeah pretty much all right what do
you think is is the government's ability
to keep us safe is it real is it all
just an illusion where do you rank Isis
on the scare factor let us know in the
comments right down below facebook has a
new privacy policy that absolutely
nobody's going to read facebook updated
its community standards guidelines
giving users more clarity on what it
sees as an acceptable post according to
the new guidelines facebook will take
down graphic images when they are shared
for sadistic pleasure or to celebrate or
glorify violence nudity will also be
removed in many cases but allow for
images of breastfeeding art and medical
conditions a blog post from facebook set
in part these standards are designed to
create an environment where people feel
motivated and empowered to treat each
other with empathy and respect for
people to treat each other with empathy
and respect which is exactly what the
Internet's all about it ah
so I always find these stories hilarious
because whenever Facebook does anything
whenever they change anything first off
we all sign it right nobody reads the 80
you have a lawyer on retainer with you
at all times every time you have to sign
something no but my father's an attorney
so I definitely take advantage of that
yeah I mean nobody does it right we
judge that not all three men no but with
other than Jack you have your dad I'll
use him too well but really we just we
just click it and then that's a fan but
I always think it's funny that everyone
goes crazy every time they change
something except correct me if I'm wrong
but isn't it a free service that no
one's forcing you to use yeah my
favorite is when people put that little
disclaimer up like you do not have the
right to use my photo it's not legally
binding right that's not that's not
tasteless in your study yeah you're like
wow you went out of the way to put a
watermark on this thing I don't think
that's gonna do anything so this is the
part the people don't get like they're
giving us these free services and the
whole point of these of them giving it
to us for free is because they're taking
us they're taking our information and if
they want to control it in a certain way
and not let us put porn on there or
violence or whatever you really have no
right to stop them right well I think
Facebook and then when my mom joined yo
its kind of edelman for me for a while
yeah but secondly it said that it's
funny it said that they won't they're
gonna ban pictures that glorify violence
so I can't put a boxing videos at UFC
videos right we can't put up how about
videos of war how about a video of you
know when I went to the Rose Bowl this
year they flew the b-1 bomber over
everybody cheered a bombing a bomber
yeah I'm killing machine and whoa so is
that also glorifying violence i think it
is you can't put pictures of the b-1
bomber up so again it's another
people trying to control other people's
morality and you can't do it right and
they also said they would ban nudity
unless it was for art reasons so so i
guess mapplethorpe could put up his rice
relax because that's arc is
breastfeeding or medical problem they
said art own art and they also said for
every artistic reasons I've like so
mapplethorpe could put a picture of
pitts Christ up and Facebook would be
okay with that right so I'll get ass too
it's you can't control people's
morality and that's what they're trying
to they're trying to make us be good
people and you can't do it right and
that's the thing what that I never
understand what this stuff is all of
this is online what
whatever degree of I want to see
whatever degree of sex you want to see I
mean this goes to the Twitter
conversation we're having earlier about
anonymous but they can't ultimately they
can't control it and if people want it
aren't they just going to go somewhere
else for it yeah but that's the whole
point I may think they're probably
trying to limit their own liability
right they're just trying to put some
parameters on what they can be
responsible for down the line if you
verify violence and someone gets killed
and they say oh it's like the old rock a
rock and roll made him do it or the
Twinkie defense yeah video game a damn
it yeah wish no study ridiculous yeah
don't even get me started on that one
yeah but I think that they're probably
just trying to protect themselves
legally and that's why they put these
things in place so that down the line
god forbid something happens they're
protected I don't think they think it's
actually gonna dictate anybody's choices
or or morality you're not gonna be a
horrible person and say you know what
because uh facebook I'm gonna be nice
yeah it's not gonna be the do you guys
do you guys think in a weird way that
we're sort of conditioned to accept
these controls you know to me like
television is totally controlled right
the FCC says what we can and can't say
in seven dirty words and all that kind
of stuff uh and the internet was totally
free for a long time it was like this
great wild west and now something's
changing we're now it's like we're
causing the internet to start censoring
are set like we're doing it to ourselves
is what it seems to me that if people
really want to facebook to be free they
they would revolt against facebook but
in a way we want these controls well
where were you know that the entire
world society is movie becoming more
brutal and angry and mean you know for
proof of this just go to any YouTube
video check out the comments section
ever read the comments do you not know
this I'm gonna talk directly there
because I know that our commenters are
not like that it for summary we've done
something good here our commenters are
good people but what's your theory you
have a theory about the theory that the
fourth comments are always mercilessly
rips the third commenters yeah and then
the fifth commenter comes in and tries
to find common ground like everybody and
for that the six commenter impinges
sexuality right okay so let's grab it
right now down below what's going on
down there I want to for some reason we
I don't know how we did it it's a
freaking miracle but our guidance keep
on point and good and all that stuff
anyway prove me right here people what
do you think about this should facebook
be censoring some of this stuff should
it just be a free-for-all do we want
these controls on ourselves in some
weird bizarre dystopian future let us
know in those comments right down below
we've done a couple stories on this
there is a massive massive drought in
California right now they are saying
scientists are saying that we literally
are a year away from having a full-on
drought so we sent our Stacy Wescoe up
to the Santa Barbara reservoir to see
what's going on hey guys I'm Stacy
Wescoe pariah news we're here in
beautiful santa barbara where we're
visiting the desalination plant that
might be going back online after nearly
twenty five-year absence to help bring
more water to the city during
california's extreme drought make sure
to check out our full report coming this
sunday for world water day and go
conserve water right now alright so
we're going to link you guys to that
report there should be an annotation
right around here or it'll be in the
description right below just a couple
other points of information on this
drought and how severe it is so right
now if you take a ten-minute shower that
uses about 10 gallons of water if you
water your lawn for 10 minutes that uses
700 gallons of water right now the Santa
Barbara reservoir is at twenty-eight
percent capacity virtually every
reservoir we have in California is at an
all-time low this strikes me as
incredibly important I saw this story
and it's like shouldn't we all worry in
California right now so just out of our
own selfish interest shouldn't we care
more about this if we're actually a year
away yeah I've been asking my landlord
to put in a dishwasher for a really long
time because that saves money and yet he
won't do it so I feel like now is the
time to get him to wait but there's a
dishwasher doesn't really because when
you're doing your dishes by hand the
running water is constantly wasting
right water I eat a lot yeah really
though shouldn't we be really concerned
about this I mean this seems this is one
of those science things and I know
people freak out when scientists
sometimes say there might be climate
change or something like that they said
we don't believe inside but if
scientists are saying we got a real
problem with our water situation in
California should we care I hate to
sound like a science denier yeah and I'm
usually not but uh if we're in such a
drastic draw
out and we're going to run out of water
in a year which is what they're saying
how come we're still in it
we're still in water clean
water every day every person in
California shits in a bucket of clean
water that's the system we
figured out I was list in Las Vegas
we're gonna get the water down there so
that's for people to drink so people can
in it in Vegas they don't and
bring the water and for drinking it's
for pissing and in perfectly
clean water this is our system we
haven't come up with another system when
we stop in perfectly clean
water that's what I believe we're in a
real drought your boss more than a dying
a gallon coming out of my foster because
right now it doesn't cost up maybe even
two cents a gallon doesn't great
anything so maybe if it was more
expensive people would stop
hosing down their driveways my
brother-in-law hoses down a
driveway you know why cuz it costs two
cents a gallon right don't we why does
it cost to dollars a gallon and people
will start conserving it you know what's
amazing about you you smoke more weed
than anyone I know and you're also the
angriest person um so to that point so
if this desalination plant that they
have in Santa Barbara if this goes up
yeah the prices of water salt out of the
water do you need to take the salt out
of the morning and I point about us
still in clean water machine
and all those rights of other guys how
to get back to that so the price of
waters gonna go up so maybe then people
will start uh you know doing more
drought resistant lawns and things like
that but the in the water so
what do you want us to do you want us to
use recycled water I don't know why I
don't know what we should be using
recycled water why doesn't it just go to
I me not to come to your house what is
it yeah well don't drink the iced tea
but why but why doesn't it go into a
hole in my backyard I just me and my
wife in our house there should
be a hole if you go there's a sanitation
issue with that yeah but I'm I'm saying
we live in a first book you buy my dog
shits outside and why somehow it gets
taken care of in the backyard why can't
I takes care no I mean equip a check the
soil berries like it's called well you
just leave your dog's to the
back here just a spot yeah
no but if I walk in i'll pick it up but
when he sits in the back here squirrel
in my backyard I don't pick it up
the raccoon in the backyard I don't
open it up what was that we were doing
we were doing something like water right
so it's just a sense that you would take
all the waste human waste mix it with
perfectly clean wall gallery and gallons
of clean water every time I go to the
bathroom it doesn't make any sense yeah
so he's part of the try to get us back
on topic here so we go in a different
direction with it yeah go somewhere go
somewhere I I was dating a guy who was
from the Central Valley went out to go
visit his family did a jog around a
reservoir and had a fair amount of water
in it and then towards the end of a
relationship about a year later yeah i
went back and there was virtually no
water and when you see something like
that you recognize where the difference
is when there's a reservoir that's
actually drying up over the course of a
year as my relationship is the water is
drying it was a beautiful metaphor isn't
it costs more money why would not supply
and demand why doesn't it I mean if they
want us to conserve make it costs more
well I think what's happening is that at
least in California is that the
politicians that are running the state
legislature up in Sacramento they know
that people refuse to pay more in it
it's the way politics always work
they're always living for the day
they're not living for what's gonna
happen next I think also part of the
problem here is that when we look at a
globe but if you look at a map it's
something like seventy one percent of
the earth is covered by water so people
can't really understand why it's autumn
all right but but I think do you think
that's part of it just visual and you
look at it you look at the earth it's
blue because of water so people can't
really understand I don't worry about it
I do wonder about those plants where
they can take the salt out of the water
I mean ago I don't know what the science
is behind that in it they work I mean
they have them in the Middle East in it
and it works but it takes a tremendous
amount of energy to do oh there you go
that's the problem then your energy
costs go yeah yeah they're gonna figure
out how to get water out of the sea
water and they're gonna figure out how
to cool the thing so talking about
things have a spirit talking they're
gonna figure out how to do it and can I
do I the science yeah wow we really just
we brought that home with science that's
what I'm talking about people anyway
what do you think are we really
you're away from a massive drought in
California it seems to be happening let
us know what you think in the comments
right down below Young Republicans are
into weed related weed is no longer cool
partisan tainan marijuana legalization
could be turning with a new generation
of millennial Republicans a new pew
research center survey has shown that
nearly two-thirds of those americans
between 18 and 35 who identify as
republicans support legalizing marijuana
use group conservative among Republicans
age 35 to 50 with forty seven percent
favoring legalization of pot the
percentage for Democrats in this age
group was 61 percent alright so we've
done a bajillion videos on weed and
every time we do a weed video I always
say that this should be a Republican
issue Republicans if you want small
government you wouldn't care with
someone smoking in their bedroom and you
also wouldn't care who someone sleeping
with right so you want to sleep with the
gay guy go ahead we're Republicans
libertarians supposed to be about
liberty but for some reason it's almost
as if the Republicans don't believe the
things that they're supposed to but
there's some hope here right isn't isn't
their actual hope here if Young
Republicans are actually sticking to the
beliefs that they're supposed to have
well I think the key in that story was
identifying as Republicans because i'm
not sure that people who identify as
republicans all the time understand what
it means to identify as a Republican in
a lot so what can we can we break that
down like that's so true that's what I
always that's what I keep saying about
this stuff that I think the Republican
they're doing themselves a mage not that
I'm trying to help them but it seems
like they're doing themselves a major
disservice I'm not standing up for the
things that they're supposed to be for I
mean a lot of people were saying well
I'm I'm a Republican but I'm socially
liberal right like well that doesn't
make you a Republican that seriously it
should make you a Republican right okk
but i like black cebu corrected by
definition i don't not sure you're a
Republican I mean I think that we have
some interesting definitions of our
social structure in our party structure
right tree um but I I wonder with stuff
like that because we were like oh well
I'm pro-choice and I'm pro-gay rights
gay marriage and I'm so when they say
there are we so when they say there
again so that really what they're saying
is they just want low taxes right thing
is I made some money
like to hang onto it right and the
estate tax I know you love the estate
tax right state tax very important my
brother who makes fifty thousand dollars
a year worries about the estate sorry
that is house out of nowhere he was we
got to get rid of that I go what is the
estate tax because that's a few died you
have millions of dollars the government
takes half of it you have a wealthy
relative we don't know about that's what
I told my but I go well let's let me
know what that becomes a problem but
until then turn off your AM radio get
invited to your own life yeah I'm sure
the estate tax is horrible but states
don't have two cars that don't work on
the front yeah exactly um if you get
that dryer fixed any day yeah the good
news here though is that but the weed
thing is sailed right like that's what I
keep saying about the gay thing it's you
know it sounds like next month or a
month and a half Dupree we think they'll
probably is going to officially make a
marriage legal throughout the country
and even if they fail on that it's going
down state-by-state it happened pretty
quick and it seems to me that weed is
just gonna follow suit right yeah I mean
more slowly it'll sit on the couch for a
while notes of munchies I see what she
did whereas the gay issue it blew down
those states right now they're just
modem down and I'm side we plowed right
through all of them just one after
another yeah do we think it's so stupid
right you're big you're big weed guy you
have a weed card I have a weed car don't
even smoke that much weed but I have a
weed card and it really has it hasn't
done any damage to you what we'd what I
forgot you're saying well listen I want
to talk about yeah of course not no I
mean they've done studies that there is
no lethal dose of marijuana there's a
lethal dose of caffeine nicotine sugar
there isn't a lethal dose of marijuana
doesn't kill people it helps you can get
stupid hi hi everyone Killian sure sure
I mean it's um you know just like all
things you know you wouldn't drink a
case of coca-cola and then try to do
needlepoint yeah right so there are
certain so that but that doesn't mean
Coco should be illegal or that it's bad
it's just you gotta use it correctly
same thing with marijuana there's a way
to use it it's hard to miss use
marijuana it's hard to make it be a
detriment a lot of time you'll hear
those people who eat marijuana and then
they'll think they're dying and they'll
call them and what I think I'm dying
right and then whether they do I had a
friend
to the emergency room yeah what they
tied they told me to just lay down for a
while right because that's literally the
worst thing that happens now on any
other thing that people realize is that
we incarcerate all these people because
of marijuana and this is this is one of
the things we're to me Obama has done a
really bad job and even in this vise
interview that he did just this past
week where they were asking him most
they took a poll from the crowd most
people want to know his feelings about
marijuana and in some ways he's been
kind of good because every time he gives
a speech about marijuana there's this
like I used to smoke weed kind of thing
on the other hand he's still even now
has the feds closing I know dispensaries
here in California so to me this is
where another one of these things where
he's kind of played both sides of the
political game it's not wanting to
alienate the older voters or the more
conservative voters yeah probably aren't
voting for him anyway right sort of odd
so he's not just weak isn't a two-term
president with only 20 months left it's
not really for that she can flat-out
because what he said in the Vice
interview basically was well you guys
should be worried about other things but
that's not that's not a leader that's
just that's just playing politics which
I don't get when you're less I'm saying
how dare you hold me my feet to the fire
on an issue that's so easily and clearly
seen for me being hypocritical
and contradictory about why would you
would you please stop bringing this up
because it makes me look bad it reveals
me for being a pure politician
yes exactly what Barack Obama is just
like everybody is he's a pure politician
and you say why why what isn't it week
why would two years left because if he
started acting courageous now why
it up right six years of being a
crowd tying presenting Republican ideas
by the way right so that's why why the
Republicans become so crazy as a wingnut
party it's because the Democrats became
Republicans and the Republicans still
have to differentiate themselves in the
Democrats so when Barack Obama says he
will do your health care plan they have
to go we can't do ours now because you
want to do it right so wait
that's what we would compromise on so
I'm getting off track right now well I
think your point is that we uh they
didn't want to do obamacare so we did
Romneycare we just called it yeah we
just so there you go anyway we'd
Republicans all that stuff what do you
think if they come around would you
consider voting Republican if you're not
a Republican right
now let us know haha right now I can
still smell weed without voting
Republican ice high fructose corn syrup
is the new superfood coca-cola the
world's largest beverage maker has been
secretly working with bloggers around
the globe to spread its message that
Coke can be a healthy treat and the
company isn't just working with any old
bloggers there specifically paying
nutritionists and fitness experts to
suggest their readers that a can of coke
can be good for you a coca-cola
spokesperson told The Associated Press
every big brand works with bloggers and
has paid talent considering soda sales
have plummeted nearly twenty percent
over the last 16 years coke may be
willing to invest a lot of money in
their own personal blogging army alright
so I would be remiss if I didn't start
with this it's one of my favorite
talking points in our coca-cola here in
America and in most of our sodas we
don't use real sugar we use high
fructose corn syrup because they figured
out a way to make corn sweeter than
sugar and it's cheaper so you have to
get a mexican coke tastes so much better
to get real show during and it actually
tastes better so that that's a sidebar
to this but people really need to
understand that that that's what these
companies are doing they're not even
giving us real sugar not the sugars good
for you we're making corn into something
sweet tell this story sounds like the
coke people are in cahoots with the
drought people because I want you to
drink more coke less water uh the
drought people from before we annotate
to that there were no you're good um
shouldn't like this I'm not for
over legal uh over controlling
everything which in like this be
illegal coke funding these things to
somehow trick people into thinking that
that is if there's an insane amount of
sugar in there everyone knows that kind
of crappy dietitian or or fitness
instructor or you if you're recommending
coke in any capacity ok you get anyone
to do anything I could pay someone
enough money they'll say anything right
Jimmy uh yes this is correct how much
you pay me sexy is he you did that well
um coat yeah coke is terrible for us
right and we drink setup I do not drink
soda pop no I just stop drinking soda
long time ago this crew a lot of bad
things only the sugar but even if you go
non-sugar uh webmaster became the acid
is bad for your teeth in your bones and
stuff like that and so it's not good for
you at all anywhere on aspartame car you
know creates tumors so
not supposed to say that cuz that's not
medically proven but I'll say yeah well
you're not a science magician you're
just the guys saying your thumb ed ins
about yeah you're allowed to say things
like that um so what do we do about
stuff like this like if they really you
know because people do buy it you know
to mean they get some croc to go on TV
and save it yeah I find this all the
time right in all these studies they can
get anyone to say anything yeah I have a
fascination with what i like to call my
skype and they use it in articles and
they use it on television when there's a
disclaimer and you can't read it yeah
right smallest thing possible right and
I feel like they say well there's a
disclaimer or they have those special
ads in magazines that are supposed to
look like real articles yeah they know
that people aren't paying attention to
the fine print right so they literally
will show you an article on one side and
then the back is all of the horrible
that it does to you right or it'll
be in ya in tiny little print where you
can't read it I mean it's like the
pharmaceutical ads or they're like see
if you know this drug is right for you
it may kill you but see if it's right
for you you can get a boner but you're
gonna commit suicide and you might choke
your wife and vomit and diarrhea etc etc
great boner yeah yeah so I think that I
think disclaimers are important but I do
think there has to be some more
regulation somewhere along the way where
people are actually forced in some
capacity to pay attention or it's more
obvious of what's going on I guess you
just have to be smarter which is what
you're gonna say I'm sure to people just
a more exciting so is that ultimately is
that what everything comes down to its
just education right we have to teach
people that when you get information
from coca-cola about how healthy
coca-cola might be that may not be the
best place to be getting your
information you know I was suspicious of
my doctor we started recommending
coca-cola but when he said camel lights
I really knew he was a bad doctor he was
a money from somebody they even got a
side that they recently just really got
revealed that the scientist from uh that
of all the big Senators quote from the
Smithsonian Institute yeah it's been on
the take from fossil fuel industries
taking million dollars over just to
produce these studies that say climate
change is happening because of solar
flare right so he's like the one guy
denying he was the one guy and he had
some position at the Smithsonian so
everyone
like to reference him and it turns out
he's completely undertake and for a
million dollars which is less money than
dr. evil as far in the 60 are we gonna
ever get this so this issue with sort of
corporations funding education or what
poses as education that's pretty much
the most important issue of our day
isn't it as corporations keep tightening
their grip on politicians well yeah I
mean it's certainly important to be a
good consumer and not just in product
but in news and information I mean I
tell people that all the time when we
talk about what's out there online I say
how do you know something's of viable
source you have to do your research you
have to look and if I read something
that sounds like a bunch of baloney I'm
gonna go out and find out whether or not
it's true on my own yeah but I know a
lot of people are very lazy when it
comes to information they read online
and they just fold it along or pass it
on without any sort of verification you
just have to be responsible for your own
information I think actually that's the
perfect ending to this one be
responsible that's why we always put the
articles in the descriptions right there
we give you a little bit information you
guys can run with it Jimmy bring me home
here I think no just you gotta question
everything you see on facebook Abraham
Lincoln said that are you in a state of
happiness right now let's find out do
you live in the happiest place on earth
no we're not talking about Disneyland
we're talking about Alaska okay so may
not be the happiest place on earth but
according to a new poll it's the
happiest state in America according to
the Gallup poll the top ten list of
happiest days also includes Hawaii South
Dakota Wyoming Montana Colorado and
Nebraska Utah New Mexico and Texas so
are you guys surprised that the two
happiest places in America aren't
attached to the rest of America do you
think there's a connection between being
far away from America in Alaska and
Hawaii and happiness what's going on
there doing yeah well I'll just tell you
about when I was one time I spent New
Year's Eve I was working on new year's
eve in Fairbanks Alaska because let's
face it I have a great agent it was 42
below zero yeah 42 below that's cold
that's what it has to warm up 70 degrees
just a freeze yeah that's cold
right and so I don't think they're so
happy just because when the Sun comes
out
in June it's such a big deal ah maybe
they took that survey in June right when
the sun is out 24 hours a day so I it
seemed like if you look at this list of
those states it's where there's least
populated states and where people in
five Montana Nebraska New Mexico you
can't see another person for days right
there's only like four people in Montana
they're all Chinese are yes exactly
there's less people in month in Montana
we're Wyoming where the Cheney's live
yeah then there are in my congressional
district in Pasadena so there's less
people in the whole goddamn state which
is why the Senate is unrepresentable
disproportionately giving more power to
smaller states that's another clip yeah
I like how you subtly fact-check me
there it's Wyoming where the chains are
from not man tactics oh I just want to
know if the Alaska poll was taken before
or after Sarah Palin oh you think
they're happier after after yeah they're
happier posts like what yeah so what is
that so the weather thing I think is
really interesting because I definitely
am hugely affected by the weather I am
much happier now in California than I
was in New York miss I wake up and it's
sunny almost all the time but we have
one and two it's Alaska and Hawaii so
obviously weather doesn't have that much
to do with it for a lot of people right
no and I didn't seem to make much sense
when I was looking at the states that
were the happiest in terms of being it
didn't it amid like I'll tell this the
the unhappiest state made a lot of sense
yeah that was West Virginia right I've
been to West Virginia lot of backwards I
can't yes no and I spent a lot of time
in that area I I get it I drove through
West Virginia not too long ago maybe
like I need it's like it's scared that's
almost like being in like The Walking
Dead Guy yeah there are some parts yeah
i remember in west virginia they had
some roads on the sign about not
littering they rhymed yeah matically
incorrect ah yeah so i could get it so
what do you make a real copulation side
of this because also these are not
populous places as you said but yet we
all want to move to cities that's where
we get done that's where a lot of
these states people stay put yeah where
they're from so there's a sense of
family there's a sense of community
there's a sense of belonging I think
when you tend to be more transient and
you
two cities like New York or Los Angeles
I'm it's probably a lot harder to make
that community because I think that this
happiness scale was based on a lot of
different factors yeah so part of it
probably is feeling like you have a home
in a place right and i think i would
imagine that if you're from some of
these less populous states and you
choose to stay hey that's the only world
you know right you don't travel as much
you don't see what else is out there and
be you have a real sense of community
within that small space right so a lot
of it also probably do with how people
define happiness so if you are just
someone that wants to work all day and
work work work then you could live in a
city probably and be very happy but if
you're somebody that wants to breathe
fresh air perhaps you might be happier
in Hawaii or something like that yeah at
you know depending again is that what
they choose to consider happiness and I
think if those people who are in those
unpopulated States who are have a fear
of the rest of the world right oh I
don't want to go to remember I was
touring unpopulated saskatoon
saskatchewan canada count 20 years ago
what everybody was there oh my god
you're from Los Angeles oh yeah you ever
been it's great oh no you get stabbed
like everyone's just what have raised
half the city of ellie's walk around
with knives and the other haps walking
Roberts night wolves yeah that's what
that's all ik if you go you're gonna get
stabbed everybody could stab everyone
yeah so that's how people feel about so
I think it's that I think it's kind of
people validating their choice to be
afraid of the world saying yeah I like
it of course so why everybody loves why
you ever been no I know but you know
what I do not someone who lives there
who doesn't love it because they feel
like they're kind of trapped they can't
really yeah but what a great place to be
trapped I'm sorry I'm trapped a baby no
but it's very expensive there's a lot of
traffic yes you don't have a lot of
options like once you're right there
you're there I mean look I I've never
been awhile places ah and I'm sure i
would love it because i love the beach
in the Sun and all that good stuff but I
had this conversation with somebody it's
this fear of fear and it's this feeling
of being confined and not being able to
drive to another state yeah I sleep I
ever had in my life was in Maui I would
go to sleep at midnight wake up at 8am
straight through never felt better in my
entire life I couldn't believe how good
I felt
yeah when I was there but to your point
about saskatoon saskatchewan up in
Canada I did the Calgary Comedy Festival
a couple years ago really and all of the
comedians were always making jokes about
Saskatchewan like that was like there go
to like our Hicks in Saskatchewan but I
met a couple people from Saskatchewan
and they seemed great like happy they're
all nice yeah they're all Pleasant
wonderful people so I don't notice happy
me in the city or assess statue on I
don't know anyway let us know what you
think in the comments right down below
and now i'm going to give jackie and
give me a chance to pimp themselves out
Jackie you can talk to that camera where
can i buy working these good people sort
of coming to my home and hanging out
with me I am on twitter at jackie
schechter Jackie with an eye schecter
you're on your own yeah I am on the
facebook jackie schechter TV and i have
a website jackie schechter calm which I
don't update as much as I should oh yeah
I will put links to all those things in
case the spelling got a little confused
Jimmy if my people don't know where you
are at this point then I don't know what
the right that's right just google jimmy
dore do re it all comes up cuz listen to
my podcast which dave has been a guest
on it's the award window back out it's
the award-winning jimmy dore show it's
the best that's been considered the best
satirical podcast in the history of
podcasting it's been considered that by
who we're not really sure anyway thanks
for watching guys and we'll do it again